for anyone just joining we're about to
run a staffer gamma tournament
and
for the very few people who maybe aren't
familiar with the staff or even it's an
opening for black it's one of my
favorites
aggressive very dubious gambits
that this is basically the starting
position
there's been
eight games in the Masters database
the engine will give
almost a decisive Advantage for whites
but I have tons of YouTube content on
this and there's so many traps that like
involve or from this position it's of
course a risky opening to play
but it can be effective against those
who maybe aren't adequately prepared
because a lot of natural
moves can walk into just some nasty
traps so I'm not going to analyze too
much before
the Tournament begins but hopefully
we'll gather a good handful of tricks
and drops okay here we go eight seven
six five star for Gambit time three
good luck everyone
what's happening
okay there we go whoa I'm black
okay hopefully I set up the position
correctly
I think I did
okay so D3 is one of the most common
moves I like that my opponent's thinking
already
so maybe they're not so well prepared
uh C3 is a move but it walks into this
move
and then it takes I have Chuck and then
the queen will fall
so this is already like a kind of tricky
line
D4
essentially I won back the pawn
um but it's playable for white do I have
Queen
h4g3
take
oh I really want to do that
this might be overly risky
five
so there's no F3
and maybe this wasn't necessary
I'm defending the knights
Knight D2 I probably have to trade
okay
that's slightly annoying
Queen F6
how will I sack the pawn
F3 yeah
King h8
breaking h8
oh no
I didn't actually address the threat
ah
that's not a good start
C5 take take
I'll try something here
yeah my phone's good enough to
just closes out
uh I have to trade Queens to what to do
any compensation
C6
okay let's play this
I have the bishop error but white has it
too
yeah and the thing is I gotta find
position two from opening
because Queen H4 was not necessary
but I'm gonna try and fight
um
this move's coming
actually no it's not
uh
A3 good move
I should probably just resign
I'll play a few more moves though
okay I resigned that was a rough start
okay it's uh it's uh Arena Gambit losing
my first game all right let's berserk
and
I'll play one
maybe so-called refutation okay three is
actually a natural move to play
okay the goal is to hold on to the pawn
defend the center
playing yup cc3
wow
opponent wanted to
actually no the pawn was pinned
okay
so I'm up three pawns here two pawns are
hanging
which one will block take
welcome back to Pam
all right let's play G4
the
the pawn that's about to be promoted
hopefully
okay H5 is looming
Chuck
ooh
I'm trying to make progress here
yeah my opponent is um
okay so bullet reading of almost two
thousand so decent player
I want to play H6
try and make some Headway on the king
side
I have to be careful
there there
let's play this first
I'm getting dangerously low on time
but Black's position isn't great the
rook's attacked
I'm ready to double up on the seventh
too
okay there's one check
I'm not taking the Rook
keep all the pressure
that's a good move though
I have to be really careful
okay 91 I play King F1
oh my queen
oh no
someone call an ambulance
yeah of course
uh if the Queen's taken it's made I
don't think black can really do much
though maybe move the Rook
oh that's a tricky move
uh let's play this
wait let's not play that
ah my time
let's go okay
oh that was really close
cutting up very very close
I almost lost to the Stafford
uh all berserk okay
let me turn on my heart you monitor
all right we'll play this one 94
D3 is a very natural move Knight C3 is a
fine move
I'll play Bishop by five
and uh can I be aggressive here
I want to be aggressive
take
all right let's take first
and C5
um
okay control the center
win back the pawn
get ready for it
not quite though
yeah White's playing well
I was trying to just win quickly but
kind of backfire there
uh let's play this
still trying to win
somehow on the king side
it's a risky move let's take
wait this ending is just worse for me
I'm gonna be down the pond
oops
let's play this
some tricks
okay I'm gonna win back this Pawn I
think
and the struggle is real
okay let's go after these Pawns
foreign
G3
repeat
okay
okay now it's winning
it's a race but I'm a little bit quicker
okay the king could catch the spawn but
then it can't catch the other pong
Gigi
oh I think you lacker docs gifting to
Sonia
all right so top ten
I'm gonna try and win the tournament
these games have been a little bit shaky
so far
have to find some rhythm
all right
I'll play D3 this time
I'll play the the so-called refutation
line
Bishop E2
H5 and then C3
and we'll see how much my opponent knows
here the idea is to play a quick D4
as black there's there's a really cool
line to try and create Chaos on the the
board
Bishop G4 I'll play F3
this is one secret uh sometimes playing
Stafford or playing against the Stafford
is white this F3 move can be very useful
preventing the Knight invisible from
using the square
and reinforcing the center
it's a question which way to Castle
staying flexible
probably King cyan
okay Connect Four traveling the bishop
it's a very aesthetic Bishop trap
oh
I'm plundered upon oh the pawn was
pinned
I was admiring my Connect Four too much
but the good thing about being Apple
Pawn is that when you lose a pawn
then it's just equal material
so I'm not down anything
and the position is still
solid
it could have been better though
I need some danger levels
yeah
and Kings should probably be elsewhere
all right we'll trade into some ending
that's a good move
yeah these games are um
are not easy
like sometimes the Stafford is
associated with quick wins
in black is maybe for Choice here the
Knight is pretty strong and generally
the queen Knight combination is
preferable over Queen Bishop
my Center looks nice but
only so much I can do with it
all right let's do this
defending two pawns attacking the Knight
because if 96 that's a move to
a very tricky move
I was more scared of Queen D4 there
go
hey it's Connect Four again
maybe this one will be more powerful
than the last one
uh let's play this
I want to play E6
okay I probably should have lost this
game
check
okay
oh that was close good game to my
opponent
I have 11 points
this FM must be stopped
and they need to try and get revenge at
some point
okay oh speaking of
let's see if my opponent has learned
their lesson from earlier
okay
already some improvements
G3 is the most common move
this is a so-called magical line
hitting F2
and now H4
so this is one reason why I still enjoy
playing the Stafford is because of this
position
it's just super chaotic objectively
White's much better like according to
the engine but
for a human to sift through the
complications
not so easy
and against most players this like
guarantees a early time advantage
Rook G1 is one of the main moves
also one of the top engine moves
yeah this is all still prep
foreign
there's a crazy line after Pawn digs
Bishop
we might get it yeah this bishop C4 line
this is uh
this is just insight and insane I have
to give credit to Jonathan trance
for discovering this
he released a video several years ago
about how to like Crush stockfish
or how to almost beat sockfish in this
line
I have to remember the prep because we
attacked the queen
Queen moves we sock The Rook take the
pawn Rook dates
and then
it's so easy for white to be losing
okay it's happening
the king is forced to the defile
there goes White's Queen
[Music]
oh it feels so good to get all the crap
hey it's vampire chicken
yeah shout out to vampire chicken
the
Ahmad also editor of many of my YouTube
videos
uh yeah we can win The Rook
why was technically like okay material
wise but just severely underdeveloped
take the pawn windy three is hard to
stop
okay that was a very feel-good game
got all the Stafford prep
and uh yeah I've
I haven't fully dismantled this person's
first place
but I've stopped their streak
I'm keeping my own streak
I got 24 minutes left
still many more games to play
all right playing E5
I've been mixing up the moves a bit
yeah Knight G4 is already uh we are not
so great move
because now yeah the knight's forced
away and
I'll try and win quickly here
calculating this this I win the queen
um
check
how to do this
I've queen of seven
Bishop E7
okay let's not take the bishop
go for Mortar
M Rosen let's go him Rose and let's go
let's go let's go him Rose and let's go
Bishop F5
wait wait
oh there's almost a funny mate there's
about five there there
it doesn't work though
I could take on E7
it takes the queen I win the queen and
make a new Queen
and if takes takes we trade and up
material
oh
okay
let's have some fun
uh check
mates okay
uh I feel bad doing that to the Staffing
but what to do
okay tied for first still on the streak
there we go uh
okay let's berserk
I'm feeling confident
okay we're going into the same line
but slightly different
yeah this is playable I'm hitting H2 now
this is one of the sources of counter
play for black
so I won back the pawn
uh but now what to do
some interesting almost end game type
position
I think the plan is to play Queen G3 and
then Rook H2
hammer away at this Pawn
A2 is kind of hanging
let's take it
because there's no Rook A1 now
there's C4 accounts defend
and invade
Bishop
is my Bishop go
play this move
oh Rook F2 Bishop C4
Queen takes C4 Queen F2 King D3 Rook D1
checkmate
oh it's so pretty
and if Rogue F2 visual C4 Knight T3
White's completely tied down
like there might be some eventual
zuzuong
okay this line I win the queen
oh no my queen
but oh yes my future Queen
okay white still has funny Pawn
structure it's like one of these um
not Jenga pieces
Tetris pieces
it's like a fake Tetris piece
okay
and it's not stalemate okay
B6 checkmates back to tournament
oh yeah I resembled How the Camel moves
up three and over one
okay that was a fun game
I mean all these games are fun
like guaranteed fund with every game
being the Stafford
now it's not too late to join you can
still uh click the link in chat we do
have the join command
and 19 minutes left in the tournament
okay another testing
testing game in the sign
oh castling this is what I taught Nemo
I think uh Bishop E7
castling's a very solid move
but there's still some attacking
potential for black
trying to remember like if each three
can I play H4 probably not
probably have to move back but
okay there's ideas of Queen G6
Etc
[Music]
actually maybe H3 Queen G6 takes takes
and then there's some each file play
can I take on each two let's do it
pure intuition here
I'm just going full YOLO and it's
probably not working
I have this move though
Jack
can I make this work
King moves and then each three
oh wow
okay I'm trying to understand what's
going on here
I don't have much time either
in G6 preparing F5
if Knight moves it moves here I win the
pawn If It Moves elsewhere I'm in this
Pawn
I do open the E file
good move okay I'm hitting the Knight
have the battery against the king
F5 is coming
Maybe
take
start by taking
I have to trade Queens
still some practical chances but it's
gonna be tough to fight back here
95 is a great move
I can't even Castle
so here here
it's going to take a lot of work to win
this
ah
okay trying to confuse the opponents
takes takes with check
oh that's a good move
oh yeah
12 seconds
foreign
oh that's kind of intense
what happened to my heart rate
connect
okay
oh okay playing this very soon
wow they have 38 points
wait how did that happen
what just happened okay let's play this
they're gonna play the same line I
played against on
or not
uh let's play this
okay I'm really trying to refute the
Safford here
using all the tools in my toolkit
it's still a little bit tricky
A4
okay I've learned my lesson from one of
those previous games
so Bishop H3 almost works but then I
have Bishop F4
a little bit unsettling
foreign
that's a good move
I think I sacked back the pawn
and Rook D1
yeah they really want revenge for that
last game
play Rook D2
B3 so this is very solid configuration
I did lose back the pawn so it is equal
material but this bishop is trapped
or hopefully a long time
oh very fancy
there there
if I take
I take I lose a queen
or do I
look at this move
C4 Knight D7 Shaq
and then Knight B6
the Knight comes to the rescue
okay opponent saw that but now The
Bishop's trapped again
rookie one on tap
um
play this move
oh good move
say this
wanna win the F Pawn
yeah the Bishops are turning
say this
defending G2
okay making some progress
or am I
Chuck
okay Rook defense D1
just have to make sure there's no
counter play
Queen E3 I take
very very tricky
I think when E3 is only chance
uh
yeah the position's not winning for me I
don't think unless
let's go back
um
thank you
well this is Pawn structure
pawns are everywhere
yeah that was a bad move
dirty fogging coming
young children close your eyes
okay blockade
that doesn't work though
get ready for it get ready for it
oh
oh I'm too slow
good game
oh I had a good position too
what to do
I think that's the first time this
tournament I lost against the Stafford
okay
not too much time left
I'm so tilted right now
I'll try and finish strong
I think people are learning what to do
against this opening
wait what
wait
have I studied this
there there
okay let's play Bishop E6
this looks good
but I'm not entirely sure
Bishop C4
wow rookie one Rook D2 Rook d8 Knight D2
I smother Fork the queen and king
but now if I play this as takes
what if I just play a quiet move
this is frustrating
doesn't seem like quiet move
let's play this
it still looks playable okay now I'm
threatening this
and this maybe
White's a little bit stuck
never too late to Castle
so I'm still down the piece but I have
two pawns for it
I also have very low time
this is almost working
I'm gonna have to do this
B6 is too slow
I have five pawns for something for rook
and Knight
oh there goes one Pawn
oh no
I'm getting hurt
oh okay
uh
okay rejoining the tournament
that was rough
okay a few more games left
still having fun that's what matters oh
playing subham
okay no berserking let's play E5
actually let's Preserve
yeah Queen H4 is a move I like to play
Knight G5
interesting maneuver
okay having threats already
we're simplifying to the end game
ooh ooh very fancy
uh
because if I play this as Queen takes
off two check
okay we're still simplifying though
wait am I driving The Rook
uh Rook ran out of the squares
okay
I don't think I can catch subham though
nice was working streak
oh this is water yeah
it's a hot day today so trying to keep
cool
all right final game probably oh
let's take
I feel like that was a playable move
oh wow I'm just wondering
oops
wait I'm in trouble here
yeah this is a lot of trouble
[Music]
I thought it was gonna be an easy like
opening win which
uh and I berserked
all right let's try and fight back let's
uh first cut the losses
optimize the pieces
look for tricks I think taking
[Music]
ticks takes
ah
doesn't work
if my Pawn's playing as well
foreign
D5
there's always chances when you have a
knight
okay this would be a nice uh Deja Vu
Rook trap
all right getting the pawns rolling
this is my bowling ball these are the
pins
play this
I'm not stopping
have to tear down everything in my
tracks
I feel like a powerful hurricane
[Music]
but how to actually okay
I think that makes life easier
a king will come in
the pawns are just too strong
nothing can stop the Pawn's desire to be
a queen
foreign
's officially over though
so what to do
oh welcome back Knight C8
if I have a c Pawn I could promote to a
nylon C8 Navy and Flint that's not
happening
Queens are born
okay
well that was fun I hope people enjoyed
the tournament
the impromptu Stafford gamut Arena nice
job to pop Milan
who uh was a highest rated player
okay I'll probably put that on YouTube
Stafford Gambit Arena
maybe it wasn't the highest quality
chess
oh look at this black wins 51 percent
slightly more powerful